[Musique]
manger boire et vivre c'est quand même
essentiel et on est quand même dans un
pays où la convivialité se retrouver sur
une table autour d'un verre c'est super
important est que de plus tous les
acteurs de la filière
il travaille plus dont ils ont plus de
revenus
ils ont énormément de salariés qui y met
beaucoup moins de revenus aussi et on
est en train de tuer un pan de
l'économie et qui nous ont tout enlever
tous nos droits qu'on avait tous les
droits qu'on a réussi à la voix pendant
des années là maintenant on n'a plus
rien on est les chemins et en plus on
est méprisée par l'état alors que sont
nous qui c'est qui va servir le
président il sait qui va servir tous les
présidents de la planète qui viennent à
l'elysée je vais vous dire je ne vois
pas du tout le couvre-feu 31 10 ans il
ose en plus nous dire parce qu'ils nous
considèrent comme les travailleurs non
essentiels on est considéré comme
travailleur en essentiel donc notre
avenir c'est de venir
esther par contre amazon il est
essentiel comme les bureaux de tabac
sont essentiels parce que ça rapporte à
l'état
voilà parce qu'un paquet de cigarettes
qui coûte 10 euros 9 euros pas dans la
poche de l'état
voilà ce qu'on veut faire de nous des
sdf
[Musique]
nous on demande qu'une chose c'est de
pouvoir de pouvoir retravailler encore
une fois on sait on sait faire appliquer
les mesures de sécurité les
distanciation on travaille avec des
audioguides on travaille avec des
microphones empathie français adapté la
situation on a toujours su adapter la
situation à notre métier pourquoi pas
maintenant